Nous sommes dans une "trocha",
un chemin de contrebande qui permet
de passer illégalement la frontière,
entre le Venezuela et la Colombie.
Émilie et ses frères et sœurs
l'empruntent quotidiennement.
Allez, on y va !
On passe par la Trocha, c'est le seul
moyen que l'on a de passer,
du Venezuela à la Colombie
pour aller étudier.
Au Venezuela, c'est difficile de trouver
du travail et la nourriture est très chère.
Tout est cher à cause
de la situation économique.
On n'a pas de quoi faire vivre la famille,
donc on n'a pas le choix,
On doit venir ici.
Un quart des migrants qui passent
par ces trochas sont des mineurs,
souvent non accompagnés.
Comme Emilie,
la plupart n'ont pas de papiers,
et ne peuvent pas traverser
le pont Simon Bolivar,
point de passage officiel
entre le Venezuela et la Colombie.
Émilie doit s'assurer
que le chemin est sûr.
Il y a beaucoup de danger
que les gens préfèrent taire.
Je ne peux pas vous dire lesquels,
parce que si je parle,
je risque de mettre en danger
ma famille et mes amis.
J'essaie de ne pas y penser et puis...
Bon, faut bouger.
La jeune Vénézuélienne de 17 ans,
a repéré un groupe armé sur l'autre rive.
Mon Dieu !
Cette zone est contrôlée par un gang,
le Tren de Aragua,
la plus puissante mafia de la région.
- Mon Dieu !
- Que se passe t-il ?
On ne peut pas filmer d'ici.
On nous a dit d'arrêter de filmer
et de partir.
Qui sont ces hommes ?
Ce sont des gens dangereux.
Allons-y les enfants !
Le Tren de Aragua est né
dans les prisons vénézuéliennes.
Et s'est imposé par sa violence.
Il a depuis étendu son influence
sur la Colombie et jusqu'au Chili.
Kidnapping, prostitution, trafic de d****,
ce gang terrorise la région
depuis trois ans.
Ils rackettent systématiquement
les migrants,
et taxent toutes les marchandises
qui transitent sur son territoire.
Une seule de ces Trochas peut rapporter,
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros par jour.
Et le Tren de Aragua
en contrôle une centaine.
Emilie n'a pas le choix, elle doit
passer par leur territoire.
En dix ans, plus de 6 millions de
Vénézuéliens ont pris le chemin de l'exil,
pour échapper à l'insécurité
et aux pénuries.
La Colombie est le principal
pays d'accueil.
La ville frontalière de Villa del Rosario,
est la première étape
sur la route des migrants.
Emily et ses frères et sœurs
ont réussi à échapper aux gangs,
et ont trouvé un autre chemin,
pour rejoindre l'église de la frontière.
Une institution qui accueille
chaque matin 90 enfants vénézuéliens.
Ça y est, je suis là !
Émilie est bénévole dans le centre.
Elle encadre les plus jeunes
depuis un an.
Là c'est Rousbailis
et elle a cinq ans.
Là c'est Wilaidis,
elle a également six ans,
et Javinar, elle a cinq ans.
Pour venir étudier ici, ces enfants
ont emprunté les chemins clandestins.
Aucun adulte ne les a accompagnés.
On va écrire un i.
Tu dessines un bâtonnet
avec un petit point dessus.
Et le 2 tu le dessine comme ça.
En plus des cours, chaque enfant
reçoit ici 2 repas par jour.
Pour les parents restés au Venezuela,
c'est souvent l'unique option
pour nourrir leurs enfants.
Face à cet afflux,
le pasteur Mauricio Miranda,
a décidé il y a six ans
de transformer son église,
en centre d'accueil pour mineurs.
Comment vous allez ?
Vous apprenez bien ?
Quelle est cette lettre ?
La lettre I, c'est bien.
Il y a des enfants de 9-10 ans
qui ne savent ni lire ni écrire.
Car ils ne sont jamais allés à l'école.
Alors les parents cherchent un système
qui leur offre une éducation,
de l'amour et de la nourriture.
Ils ne vivent pas une vie d'enfants.
Mais pendant qu'ils sont
dans notre centre,
ils peuvent redevenir des enfants.
Retrouver leur vraie nature.
Mais le pasteur ne peut s'occuper
des dizaines de mineurs,
livrés à eux-mêmes dans Villa del Rosario.
Il y a beaucoup d'enfants
entre 13 et 16 ans,
qui sont venus seuls
de plusieurs villes du Venezuela.
Alors maintenant, ils se retrouvent
sans papa ni maman,
et donc leur seule famille,
ce sont d'autres enfants du même âge.
Dans ce quartier de La Parada,
tenu par les gangs,
les enfants sont une proie facile.
Sur ces chemins,
ils disparaissent régulièrement.
Mauricio Miranda est l'un des rares
à pouvoir s'y rendre sans crainte.
Dans ce quartier, il y a des groupes
qui font du trafic d'êtres humains,
et chaque enfant est une cible
potentielle, s'ils en ont besoin.
Donc ces enfants peuvent disparaître,
être vendus,
être adoptés de force contre de l'argent.
Ils peuvent en faire ce qu'ils veulent.
Je ne sais pas vraiment
où ils finissent.
Je n'ose même pas y penser.
Mais l'imagination de ceux qui
contrôlent ce trafic est sans limites,
quand il s'agit de faire de l'argent.
Que risque une personne
qui dénoncerait ce trafic ?
On le kidnappe,
on le frappe,
et même pire... La mort bien sûr.
Ça dépend de ce que vous avez dénoncé.
Depuis 2015,
le gouvernement colombien estime,
que 25 000 mineurs
vénézuéliens non-accompagnés,
auraient franchi la frontière
entre les deux pays.
La Colombie partage 2000 kilomètres
de frontières avec le Venezuela.
La contrôler est illusoire.
La police fait de rares incursions
dans les Trochas de Cucuta.
Ce matin, une cinquantaine de policiers,
investissent un chemin de contrebande.
Allez les gars, on contrôle le terrain.
Une opération de communication,
qui chasse les gangs
le temps d'une patrouille.
Mais qui n'interrompt pas
l'immigration clandestine.
Nous sommes sur un chemin illégal,
ce que l'on appelle une Trocha.
Sur la frontière avec
notre voisin le Venezuela.
Cette Trocha s'appelle le chemin des
mangues en Colombie.
chez nos voisins,
elle porte un autre nom.
Nous avons une patrouille de police,
qui accompagne une équipe
des services de l'immigration,
qui vont contrôler les allées
et venues sur notre territoire.
Ce dimanche, de nombreuses familles
se rendent illégalement en Colombie,
pour y acheter de la nourriture
et des médicaments.
Venez, madame.
Donnez-moi la main.
Voilà, c'est bien.
La police n'a pas
pour mission de les arrêter,
mais de vérifier que
des mineurs non-accompagnés,
ne se soient glissés dans le groupe.
Cette famille arrive du Venezuela,
et n'a pas de documents pour ses enfants.
Je n'ai pas leurs pièces d'identité.
Ce sont des mineurs.
Vous devez les avoir.
Vous savez qu'avec des enfants,
vous devez passer par le pont.
C'est bon pour cette fois.
Un simple rappel à l'ordre et les enfants
passent sans aucune vérification.
Allez, viens, c'est par ici.
C'est ainsi que les mineurs
non-accompagnés,
réussissent à franchir la frontière.
Dénoncer ces trafics,
c'est risquer sa vie.
Christian Herrera, journaliste
d'investigation au journal L'opinion,
le sait parfaitement.
Il enquête depuis 15 ans sur les liens
troubles entre mafias et autorités locales.
Il est protégé 24h/24.
J'ai reçu de nombreuses menaces de mort.
On m'a même donné 24h
pour quitter la ville.
Et donc, face à cette situation,
l'État m'a placé dans un programme
de protection des journalistes.
On met à votre disposition une voiture
blindée comme celle-ci,
et des gardes du corps.
Ce matin, direction la frontière
avec le Venezuela.
C'est un endroit
où il y a eu des disparitions,
et des assassinats.
Le quartier de l'Escobar est à 20 minutes
du centre ville de Cucuta.
Christian enquête sur les groupes
qui contrôlent les trafics frontaliers.
Chaque jour, près de 15 000 personnes
traversent ce pont.
Plus du double passent illégalement
la frontière par les Trochas.
Sur ce pont, on ne peut pas
faire du commerce.
- Pourquoi ?
- C'est illégal.
Les gens utilisent les Trochas ?
Oui, c'est le seul moyen
de passer des marchandises.
Combien coûte le passage ?
Je ne sais pas. Nous on passe par
le pont parce que c'est plus sûr.
Le droit de passage
prélevé par les gangs,
serait en fait de 1 à 20€ par colis.
Je peux vous dire, que pour chacun
de ces petits passages,
un groupe armé illégal
empoche 30 000$ par jour.
Et donc c'est très dangereux pour
les mineurs qui n'ont pas le choix,
et doivent traverser cette frontière.
Car ces groupes peuvent les recruter,
les violer ou les faire disparaître.
Tout le monde sait ce qu'il
se passe dans les Trochas.
Tout le monde sait qui les dirige
et quel trafique s'y déroule.
Mais personne ne veut lutter contre ça.
Ni le gouvernement, ni la police.
Tout le monde esquive !
Ils vont jusqu'à un certain point
et ils s'arrêtent.
Car s'ils franchissent cette limite,
ils vont devoir se battre.
Il y a des groupes qui donnent
de l'argent à la police,
pour qu'ils les laissent travailler en
paix. Travailler entre guillemets,
trafiquer à la frontière, la frontière.
L'un des trafics les plus lucratifs
est la prostitution.
Parmi les migrants, ce sont les jeunes
filles qui sont les plus vulnérables.
C'est dans ces rues
qu'elles sont repérées.
Michelle a 16 ans.
Elle est arrivée il y a 2 ans du Venezuela,
et doit se prostituer pour vivre
et nourrir son enfant.
Voici mon bébé et c'est là que je vis.
Michelle loue cette pièce 2€ par jour,
l'équivalent de deux passes.
Ça, c'est tout ce que j'ai.
Et là, c'est le matelas
pour tous les deux.
50 femmes et enfants,
tous originaires du Venezuela,
logent ici dans une situation précaire.
Michelle rend visite
à une nouvelle arrivante.
- Bonjour Diana, comment vas-tu ?
- Bien, maman.
- Et ton bébé ?
- Comme-ci, comme-ça.
Diana a 14 ans.
Elle a traversé la frontière il y a
deux semaines avec son bébé,
et n'a plus un sou en poche.
Tu sais, aujourd'hui, je vais devoir
travailler pour payer le loyer.
Moi, je dois 4 jours.
La propriétaire me le réclame aussi.
Elle est venue me voir et m'a dit que si je
ne réglais pas aujourd'hui, je devrais partir.
Si Diana ne trouve pas de solution,
dès demain,
elle et son bébé seront à la rue,
sans aucune protection.
Un sort trop souvent partagé
par ces adolescentes,
qui n'ont plus qu'une solution
pour survivre.
Il y a des filles qui ont entre 11
et 13 ans et qui se prostituent aussi.
Et ici, il y a plein de gens méchants
qui sont capables de tout.
Souvent, quand je suis dans la rue,
la nuit, ils viennent m'emmerder.
Il t'est arrivé des choses difficiles ?
Oui.
Un jour je bossais et des mecs m'ont
embarqué dans un endroit inconnu.
Ils m'ont emmené mon tabasser,
et puis ils m'ont abandonné sur place.
La majorité des filles finissent sous
l'emprise des réseaux de prostitution.
À Cucuta, la capitale régionale,
Alejandra Vera, avocate et activiste,
vient en aide à ces adolescentes.
Dans ce refuge gardé secret,
elle a recueilli cinq jeunes filles
qui ont échappé à leur souteneur.
Bonjour mesdemoiselles,
comment allez-vous ?
Par peur des représailles,
elles resteront anonymes.
Pour les aider à se reconstruire,
Alejandra les écoute et les conseils
afin qu'elles réalisent,
que leur rêve d'une vie meilleure
n'était qu'une illusion.
Vous vous imaginez, la Colombie,
il y a de la nourriture, du travail.
C'est ce qu'on vous avez dit
et arrivé ici,
vous vous êtes rendu compte
que c'est un mensonge.
Un mensonge auquel elles ont cru
jusqu'à la frontière.
C'était horrible.
Quand je suis passée par la Trocha,
j'ai dû tout donner.
Ils m'ont dit qu'ils me tueraient
et j'ai eu très peur.
Ensuite, j'ai suivi une personne
qui m'a emmené jusqu'à Pamplona.
Et là, on m'a drogué. On m'a manipulée.
On m'a prostituée et je suis restée
là-bas pendant deux semaines.
Ce sont des gens qui apparaissent et qui te
disent :
"Je peux t'emmener chez moi,
je vais m'occuper de toi.
Il y a d'autres femmes
qui vont te protéger."
Rendez vous compte, il y a 200 adolescentes
qui passent cette frontière chaque jour,
et 80% d'entre elles disparaissent.
C'est un sujet tabou.
Personne n'ose en parler.
Les jeunes qui échappent
aux pièges de la frontière,
choisissent souvent de rejoindre Bogota
à 600 kilomètres de là.
La route 55 est le moyen le plus rapide
pour atteindre la capitale colombienne.
Mais c'est également la plus dangereuse.
Elle traverse un territoire contrôlé
par l'ELN, une guérilla marxiste,
qui recrute de force des enfants soldats.
C'est l'itinéraire
qu'ont choisi d'emprunter,
Miguel, Khider, Jordan et Amber.
Le plus jeune à 15 ans, le plus âgé 17.
On arrive bientôt ?
J'ai envie de me laver
et de me changer.
Ça fait une semaine que l'on marche.
On a laissé notre famille au pays
pour avoir un avenir meilleur.
Quand on est fatigué,
on se repose et puis on repart,
jusqu'où nos pieds nous porterons.
Ces amis d'enfance, originaires de Caracas,
ne se séparent jamais.
Ils se refusent à faire de l'autostop.
C'est une règle d'or.
Malgré toutes ces précautions, impossible
d'échapper aux dangers de la route.
On n'a plus rien, on n'a pas de vêtements,
on s'est tout fait voler.
Même nos chaussures, nos vêtements,
le peu de nourriture qu'on avait,
les papiers, l'argent qu'on gardait
pour prendre le bus.
On n'imaginait pas
que ce serait aussi difficile.
Parce que c'est la première fois
qu'on voyage.
Même si on nous avait dit que c'était
dangereux et qu'il fallait faire attention.
Les voleurs nous ont pris
les uns après les autres,
si on n'avait rien donné, ils nous
menaçaient de nous découper à la machette,
de nous tuer à coups de couteau.
Et si tu voyages avec une femme,
c'est pire.
Ils les attrapent,
les violent et les tuent.
Sur la route, il y a des gens qui nous
voient et qui nous proposent de nous emmener.
Mais ça, pas question !
Ils t'embarquent,
ils t'emmènent quelque part,
et on ne te revoit plus jamais.
La prochaine étape où ils pourront
trouver un refuge,
est à 10h de marche.
Pamplona est perchée
à 2500 mètres d'altitude.
Ils ont appris qu'un gîte offre
l'hospitalité aux migrants.
- Bonsoir.
- Comment allez vous ?
- Bien.
Dites-moi,
vous avez fait toute la route ?
Allez, rentrez.
Marta Duquet a transformé sa maison
en refuge pour migrants il y a six ans.
Asseyez-vous.
Je vous trouve bien jeune.
Pourquoi voyagez vous seul ?
Parce que chez nous, tout est difficile.
On a souvent faim.
On a décidé de venir ici
pour trouver un travail,
et envoyer de l'argent à nos mamans,
pour qu'elles s'en sortent parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de travail.
Et que pensent vos familles du fait que
des enfants aussi jeunes voyagent seuls ?
Plein de choses peuvent vous arriver.
Beaucoup ne sont jamais revenus.
Rien. On leur a dit :
"C'est pour trouver du travail".
Quatre jours plus tard,
on était sur la route.
Marta héberge et nourrit
jusqu'à 30 personnes par jour.
Tout est financé par elle
ou par des dons.
Là c'est notre cuisine.
Vous aurez à manger
et là, c'est le dortoir.
Bonjour à tous,
je vous amène 4 jeunes mineurs.
On va leur faire
une place pour la nuit.
Khider, Miguel, Jordan et Amber,
dormiront au chaud
et en sécurité cette nuit.
Marta, quant à elle, prend soin
de consigner chaque nom,
et chaque histoire de migrant
qu'elle héberge.
Un registre qui permet également
de comptabiliser les disparitions.
De tous les jeunes qui
sont passés par ce refuge,
il y en a 40 à 50 qui ont été
officiellement déclarés disparus.
Et ça, ce ne sont que les cas connus.
La police ne s'intéresse pas vraiment
à la protection des jeunes migrants,
parce qu'ils ne font pas ce genre de travail,
et ils n'ont pas d'unités spécialisées
pour faire des contrôles sur ces routes.
C'est juste quand on leur rapporte
une disparition qu'ils agissent,
mais sinon, ils ne les protègent pas.
J'ai jamais eu aussi froid de ma vie.
6h du matin,
il fait cinq degrés dans le gîte.
Marta prodigue ses derniers
conseils autour d'un café.
Faites très attention car Bogota
est une ville dangereuse.
Vous pouvez être victime
de plein d'embrouilles,
et vous mettre dans de sales histoires.
Pour rejoindre Bogota, Anders,
Miguel, Khider et Jordan,
devront encore marcher 12 jours.
Allez, tchao les enfants !
Faites attention et prenez soin de vous.
Merci.
Les quatre jeunes vont affronter
la Cordillère des Andes,
une chaîne montagneuse
aux températures glaciales,
vêtus de simple T-shirts et de sandales.
Depuis le début de l'année,
selon l'UNICEF,
500 jeunes vénézuéliens
ont emprunté la route 55.
Parfois, leur trace se perd
dans ces montagnes.